when do it
coming
hey hey
hey
hey hey like she said winter is coming
so that means we got to get everything
ready for
coming yeah so it's going to be in the
single digits around here um this coming
this weekend so we're going to get all
the animals out fitted with heat lamps
and fresh straw to lay on puppy dogs
love their
straw uh turkeys will be brought uh well
they're well they're they're pretty good
they're pretty good
so um we'll just need to make sure that
their water doesn't freeze or nothing
off and play sure you can go off and
play
we're going to clean out the brooder
side of the
barn let the turkeys hole up in there
for a little
bit we'll make sure that the
uh the bees don't need anything which
they they look like they're doing pretty
good like they look like they got
themselves all sealed up real tight
so we're going to move the chicken water
inside they can come out and get water
but they're not going to want to we're
going to let them we're going to open
the door for them to come out every day
but usually they just like to hang
around their uh their heat Source until
things go back to kind of like it is now
in the 30s to 40s that kind of where
they're at the main thing with chickens
is just making sure that they're uh they
have a if they get wet they have the
ability to dry themselves off and they
don't stay wet because their Combs will
get frostbite like that and uh then
you'll get infection and they'll start
walking around with brain worms and and
everything just not acting
right hey why don't you like And
subscribe we got weekly videos and hey
we do shorts all the time too and hey
we're going to be getting our St ready
for hey the winter that's coming this
weekend
hey so hey that's what we're doing here
to keep our livestock uh through this uh
next week what what kind of stuff are
you doing to keep them ready do you have
a good place for them to go or you just
now don't get caught with your pants
down you know especially in cold weather
because you'll get frostbite on your
butt nobody likes
that but hey drop a drop a hey drop a
comment hey drop a comment down below
what kind of stuff you're doing to keep
your livestock
alive la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la la
[Music]
la
L la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la la la
[Music]
oh
what are you doing with it I'm just
going to kind of spread
it in fact it's so small in here we
might just give them half of it yeah
they don't need all of it and give the
chickens the other
half you don't need
anybody I like some
work
[Music]
going be in there that many
days it's so many water and
food all right now is this your room now
think I got my own room no I did
not go back out there we're going to
give you
some just a second just go back out
there no buddy come on you get some out
here we'll put it all over the
place okay look bie look
bu come come
on tou the
it think it'll keep them warm
bar they're not enough room for Somers
sauce in there Barney all right come on
bud come on
buddy
I
[Music]
l l l l l l
l la la la la la la la la la la la
[Music]
la
right
you ready you
ready look what we
got can I have it I'm going to spread it
for you can I have
it have
it
bie good boy good boy good
boy fancy are rolling the
straw hey it is there it
is there he is good boy good boy
hey who's a good boy who's a good
boy good
boy some
more good boy good boy good boy
yay you good boy B
you show mommy your bed is it your bed
Barney that your
bed you're welcome you're
welcome need you're
welcome all
right
[Music]